I'm scared that when we come out of here
the devastation
and the loss of lives would be
I'm too scared mark
this is San Juan Mayor Carmen you lean
crews hours before Hurricane Maria would
make landfall on the eastern tip of
Puerto Rico
that night as I was barricaded in a
hotel with staff and stranded tourists
the storm raged above shredding the
islands electrical grid and cutting
power to the entire island it was the
strongest storm to hit the island in
nearly a century when Maria left dazed
Puerto Ricans emerged to find flooded
streets and destruction in every
direction they had no power no phones no
water we're in downtown Sun fun right
now and this is what it looks like
50% of these streets were flooded and
for many residents it be wading through
water just to get home what's it been
like
stunned and waiting for government aid
they look to each other for help well if
we're not does at home sitting waiting
for something to happen you know or for
the government to do something for us
who actually see that we could do
something and we're trying to get on to
help but for an island already suffering
from more than seventy billion dollars
in debt and an exodus to the US mainland
many fear this storm will have
devastating consequences for decades to
come
[Music]
a month after the storm I returned to
see how the island was recovering during
that time FEMA had arrived but mounting
criticism of its response was setting up
a debate about how much the US
government felt obligated to spend on
recovery president Trump had also
visited setting off a firestorm over his
tweets and public statements as we've
spent a lot of money on Puerto Rico and
that's fine do you look at a real
catastrophe like Katrina today much of
the island is still without power
including large swathes of the capital
Sun Quan many still have no access to
drinking water and struggle with ongoing
fuel and food shortages we enter a
community to the West called barrio
playa and Yasko local authorities are
still working to remove large piles of
trash and debris we find a man who calls
himself people de la revolucion
or people of the revelations he lives in
a small compound with his wife and
adopted daughter along with members of
his extended family
see you say you're a friend okay Patera
todo Ostia oh the yeah
so they said he went around me post
Yellin in upon me away we make it Akiko
labeija para la vida para la nina Mia
chromakey okiru-okay Inaba your girl
you're saying the government income no
Lola Tara Nick one person and tell me
nah nah you gotta pass a togepi right
now we're in on Yasko this is one of the
hardest hit areas here in Puerto Rico
and as you can see over my shoulder the
Red Cross is distributing food and water
for the residents who are gathered here
as a tropical island Puerto Rico depends
heavily on tourism to support its three
and a half million residents though all
American citizens most earn much less
than their mainland counterparts a month
after the storm and residents say this
is only the second time any organized
relief has come to their town on the
eastern tip of the island where the
hurricane made landfall the damage is
astonishing a man goes about his day his
house collapsed all around him
powerlines electrical towers trees and
buildings lie in every direction
[Music]
so we just arrived in penile velocity
and every single place you look you
either see down power lines poems that
are completely demolished or homes that
are simply not even there anymore we
also know that there are some cases of
leptospirosis and hepatitis here locals
tell us this is where they got their
drinking water in the weeks after the
storm it smelled of sewage and rotten
eggs we know that in the absence of
having any clean drinking water people
across party Rico we're digging wells
but we don't even know where this water
is coming from they tell us that people
just simply came here to fill up water
and left with it despite all the damage
the primary concern is still basic
necessities like drinking water
Oscar carrion turned his restaurant into
a makeshift shelter for families that
lost their homes
walkies it's a simple simple intimacy or
as a Kusadasi okay yeah see if I'm
allowed I mean more yeah when I persona
okay now say yeah and which are normal
which are cars again awesome Taryn
but we like it how do you feel driving
around this neighborhood it looks like
the hurricane happened yesterday exactly
this is not moving anywhere I mean it's
very slow so that's kind of we're
desperate for that so this is kind of
the way through social media they can
see the reality of what's going on
sometimes in the news you don't get
everything you don't get old stories so
and what's the reality how would you
describe what's happening people we need
people hungry people that lost
everything house and half eating clothes
nothing to feed their kids water for
even for us in the cities is hard to get
water
Puerto Rico is fundamentally different
than Houston after Harvey Florida after
Emma or even New Orleans after Katrina
the federal response was shrouded in
criticism from the start with widespread
evidence that families were not having
even their most basic needs met for many
the colonial nature of the federal
government's relationship with Puerto
Rico came into laser focus and became a
dark cloud hanging over the aftermath of
the storm unions and NGOs were
consistent in their assessment that the
feds were failing some even said that
the situation amounted to a violation of
basic human rights we know that there
have been cases of leptospirosis here
some say that there's hepatitis here
because of the water have you seen any
of that do you know anybody who's sick
with leptospirosis vito's goomah semana
well not so many kind of I mean today I
have you gotten a lot of help from FEMA
or from the government have you seen
FEMA in your neighborhood helping people
here out like these volunteers believe
me done
10:7 Iran Bora gossip or Gaza at FEMA
headquarters in San Juan officials
admitted significant work lies ahead
what is FEMA accomplished up to this
point so far I always hate trying to
capture at this because there's still so
much to do and and we're focused on that
future but as far as it's going I think
we've met the feeding need the water
need the the emergency shelter needs and
stabilize the health care system I think
we've got a fragile but stable situation
right now in Canova nas there have been
cases of leptospirosis
what is FEMA's plan to prevent the
waterborne illnesses from increasing we
have a plan we have a network of we've
restored the hospital Network we've
restored the dialysis centers the
pharmacies are all open they're able to
do transactions and we're aggressively
pushing out to those areas where that
that's going on in the weeks after the
storm Donald Trump added explosive
controversy to the federal response now
I hate to tell you Porto Rico but you're
throwing our budget a little out of
whack
we're gonna help you out thank you have
a good time the backlash among critics
has remained fierce the mayor of San
Juan being one of the most vocal this
administration does not want to listen
to the truth and does not want to own up
to it the federal government's response
to Puerto Rico's tragedy and
humanitarian crises has been inadequate
has been insufficient and plainly it has
been a way for the Trump administration
not to comply with their moral
obligation to help the people of Puerto
Rico the situation is still a
life-or-death situation president Trump
fired back at repeated criticisms from
mayor Cruz he even took a job at Puerto
Ricans themselves saying they want
everything done for them it was clear
that a politically charged information
war was being waged and post-hurricane
Puerto Rico was the battleground in Newt
wardo a mountainous region in the
islands interior we arrived at a
collapsed bridge it's become a widely
publicized symbol of both the
desperation and the strength of local
communities since the storm locals send
donated supplies across the river in a
shopping cart fixed to a makeshift
zipline
an entire neighborhood of elderly people
live here
the everyday reality for them is that
without the bridge their community is
cut off from the main road and they have
no entrance or exit you're a boy Asahina
dugong don't those with family on the
other side are overwhelmed at the side
of the bridge multiple groups pull up to
deliver donations by hand and what are
you doing here today I'm wait we saw
last night on the news what was going on
here so this morning we went down and
bought as much food as we can fit in the
car water ice and just came you know
because we know that the United States
government isn't doing anything so the
people here in the island have to take
care of themselves we met Paul Santiago
at the bridge who initially came to
Puerto Rico to help family members and
stayed when he noticed a lack of
response from federal and local
authorities they could put a bridge here
overnight it's hard to understand and
being I was the first 11 years of my
life
a - the first 11 years I lived here
coming back to this it's heart-wrenching
I've been here since October 4th I have
not seen a single person for FEMA not
not on he talked or Assad but I kita Jo
entiendo que Camino del camin at the
Femina wedding entrance pero la forma de
Paseo
aqui mindful mother passin camin est
pasando iowa yellow una bella noticias
see my sake free mr. caffee mr. Holloway
right now we're crossing over from one
side of this river to the other and
we're taking advantage of the fact that
it's a dry day that there's no rain
because when it rains there's absolutely
no access to the other side
we met Marilyn Luciano Soto a community
leader for this neighborhood has FEMA
come and help you guys as FEMA actually
come and try to remedy this situation I
mean it's been 35 days and you guys
still have Army Navy US Air Force all
the militaries and some of them like yes
like two days ago um some loose eastern
rotation with FEMA and I'm chicken they
came to bring us some water and some
MREs
I appreciate and so does my community my
community appreciate everything that
they bring me but um sometimes I think
um it's sometimes I think it's a waste
what do you want people to know about
what you guys are going through 35 days
later what's the hardest part and what
do you need the most the most urgent
thing is a bridge because that's our
only weight so the rest of the world so
why has there been no action that's what
I asked myself one thing became clear
there was a disconnect between the
efforts FEMA and the local authorities
claimed they were making and the people
who were most in need
as we prepare to leave loot waddle to
officers in uniform arrived they were
from the Army Corps of Engineers and
despite a clear aversion to our cameras
they were happy to carry on a casual
conversation her cameraman captured some
audio of what they had to say about the
bridge I got a few good evening tonight
this is a communicator they explained
that a Bailey bridge a type of temporary
bridge could be erected in three hours
you got well many people mm-hmm that
have no experience in and they can make
a decision
back at FEMA headquarters I asked about
the engineers thoughts on the Bailey
bridge if it takes three hours to
install wouldn't that really alleviate
the suffering of those 24 people I think
there were multiple ways to take care of
people and and that's not the only
bridge we have down we literally have
four or five dozen bridges that have
been severely impacted and we have roses
that are washed out and we have roads
that are still at risk of collapsing and
in Toronto the highway going through
there tomorrow is one of them you know
but I would tell you a half a mile away
from there is one of our what we call
our RSA's our supply areas and there was
literally you know you know thousands of
liters of waters and thousands of meals
right there you know and and it's really
not that far in that hard to get to get
it to those families and we also have to
prioritize you know we want to take care
of everybody that's our goal but it's
gonna take time that same day San Juan
mayor you dean kruse traveled to
washington DC to testify in front of
Congress when I got off the plane in
Washington DC we found out that the
hearing had been cancelled with
parent reason I think it's in it's an
attempt to silence the voices that I
represent because it isn't my voice
that's important it's the voices that
are represented by me and the plight of
the people of Puerto Rico in Puerto Rico
it is still life or death for many
president Trump boasted of the death
toll remaining at sixteen but that
number is widely disputed rhetoric and
media reports that since Maria 911
bodies had been cremated without proper
autopsies many may be storm-related and
a CNN investigation finds the death toll
is well into the hundreds it's not that
President Trump does not get it is that
he doesn't want to get it and that
contrasts very sharply with the more
than 500 volunteers that we've had in
San Juan that have left their homes
taken vacation and come with open hearts
to help the people of San Juan and more
than 34 communities outsider
hey this is Ahmed thanks for watching
and please subscribe to aj+ for more on
Puerto Rico as well as more
documentaries like this and don't forget
to check out the rest of the series
where we investigate the long term
recovery efforts on the island as well
as meet people who are fleeing to the
mainland